foreign
good morning everybody sorry for the
delay
um this is what happens when you take
too long a Break
um before we get started we can all rise
okay
um I'm gonna open up the executive
session on Senate Bill 13 FN relative to
the recovery of search and rescue
expenses
chair recognizes representative Sykes
oh sorry about that I can I can
recognize representative thank you
representative Vale thank you Mr
chairman I move that we retain
SB 13. okay motions to retain is there a
second
seconded by representative Dumas would
you care to speak to motion sir
uh yeah this this bill is uh
kind of conflicts with a bill that we
already retained it would be uh probably
prudent to kind of work on them together
to make sure that we keep the laws
consistent
yeah thank you for that anybody else
from the committee
seeing Monday I'll just add the bill
that we did retain is house bill 650.
um that one being in question and being
worked on this would just add another
thing to that list so even though I
support this in theory that's just me
I'm okay with the routine it with
nothing else nobody else from the
committee I'll ask the clerk to call the
rule motion is to retain Senate bill 13.
Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
debase yes representative Melvin yes
representative foot
yes representative C yes representative
sellers
yes representative Sykes yes
representative Rich yes representative
Horrigan
yes representative Fox yes
representative Rambo yes representative
yes representative Schultz yes
representative Jones yes representative
Jack yes representative Staub yes and
chairman Walsh yes
28-0 okay the motion to retain is
approved or adopted 20-0 I'll close the
executive session on Senate bill 13.
one moment and we'll go on to Senate
okay I'm gonna open up the executive
session on Senate Bill 118 FN requiring
children under the age of two years to
be restrained in a motor vehicle
the chair recognizes representative
Sykes for a motion
okay Mr chairman I move
ought to pass
that motion is
okay was that representative Jones yes
that was moved by representative Sykes
the enthusiasm is Awesome seconded by
representative Jones
um representative Sykes would you care
to speak to emotion I would Mr chairman
thank you
um this Bill had a long
list of supporters and Technical data
that made this be the right thing to do
for example
um
Dartmouth Health
talked about how the American Academy of
Pediatrics the CDC they both recommend
uh rear-facing car seats for infants
data on this issue is fully in support
of rear-facing car seats and TSB also
does research on car seats for children
interestingly Dartmouth Health can
actually provide car seats for families
that are needy so it's there's not a
huge expense for those people who can't
afford them
um uh Dan Goodman from the AAA testified
in favor of this bill almost all
independent studies corroborate that
rear-facing car seats are better for the
survivability of the occupants
and he made note of the fact that it's
education engineering and finally
enforcement that helps create a safe
environment for people who are
amongst the most vulnerable members of
our motoring public and for that reason
I fully support OTP
thank you sir thank you anybody else
really oh representative sakes I mean uh
sellers sorry yeah thank you Mr chair
I'm going to probably vote against this
bill because you know
it's just another burden on the parents
which I think are very responsible to
start out with and caring for the young
children at this point
and also I think it's this is designed
to only a specific group of people and
not all people because not everybody has
a child under two years old and
therefore we're creating a law just for
a specific group of people and it should
wow okay I'll I will add my two cents in
because I did vote for this bill last
term
um since then I've had my my most
important constituent my mother tell me
that I was crazy and she never would
have done that to me because it's cruel
so I'm going to vote against the ought
to pass this time uh for another couple
of reasons I
while I agree that it's a common sense
measure and we heard from AAA that even
the hospitals won't usually let kids out
of the hospital until they are in a
rear-facing child seat so it sounds to
me like the parents are getting the
information
my other problem is with enforceability
I haven't seen any two-year-olds go
around with IDs saying they're two so I
don't really know what this has
accomplished what this accomplishes uh
so with that I will be voting against
the ought to pass anybody else from the
committee
representative Morgan
um this bill came up two years ago we
had a very memorable
extremely long floor debate on it and
the upshot of it this time that time the
virtually identical Bill originated the
house and the upshot of it was that this
became a study the Senate turned a study
committee in the study committee of
course recommended uh in favor one I
think is a pretty Common Sense law if
you know to restraint backwards but we
did have
um those of us who were here two years
ago did have what's either
which either amusing or painful but like
an incredibly long floor debate about it
with many many motions but um we'll see
what happens uh this year no thanks
oh I will agree with you representative
Horrigan I will never forget it I'm in
the painful category uh I would expect
we'll have a colorful debate on it once
again with nobody else from the
committee I'll ask the clerk to call the
rule the motion is ought to pass on
Senate bill 118.
Vice chairman Gorski no
representative Smith no
clerk votes yes
representative Hill nope
representative domains no representative
Melvin
no representative Foote
no
representative C
no representative sellers
no representative Sykes
yes representative rich
yes representative Horrigan yes
representative Fox
yes representative Rambo yes
representative yes representative
Schultz yes representative Jones yes
representative Jack yes representative
stop
11 to
9.
so yep so the motion about to pass is
well the recommendation for ought to
pass is adopted 11-9 uh I'll close the
executive session on Senate bill 118.
a couple of moments we'll move into 187
before we do does everybody have a copy
there is an amendment that is being
proposed if you don't they are there are
okay
I'm going to open up the executive
session on Senate Bill 187 FN relative
to driver's licenses for certain Visa
holders uh chair recognizes
representative Smith for a motion thank
you Mr chair I move out to pass motion
is ought to pass is there a second
second second by representative Fox
okay uh this bill is open for further
Amendment chair recognizes
representative Smith thank you Mr chair
is there a second motion is uh to pass
on the amendment second okay
representative Fox again
I forget did you want to speak to this
or am I doing it I will defer to the
okay
um those of you that were here you may
remember we saw this basic same bill
last term
uh we uh actually I believe retained it
in the first year interim studied it the
second year uh and every time we tried
to solve a problem came up with another
question
the
the onus of what we kept discussing was
how to get these agricultural workers
with an h2a Visa a New Hampshire
driver's license because as we heard the
farmers the Apple farmers in particular
are now getting fined by the United
States Department of Labor for not
complying with New Hampshire law which
requires they get their driver's license
I started looking at this a little
different I have to tell you we put a
um
and we decided to look at it differently
knowing
again excuse me that anybody from
Jamaica for example that's some of the
ones we're talking about if they came to
the United States on vacation they could
drive on the roads of the State of New
Hampshire with their
Jamaican driver's license currently and
so I in in an effort to solve this
problem
we decided to go with that that they can
already drive with their license on the
states the roads of the state and just
extend it from the 60 days to 300 days
which is what it's prescribed on line 17
and 18 of the amendment the rest of the
bill stays the same again if you read
the amendment
it just replaces section let's do this
replaces after section one the amendment
and then the original section two will
read a section three which is the
effective date so that's what it does in
other words in summary for h2a
agricultural workers they can drive with
their out-of-country license while
they're here working for 300 days if
they're if they overstay that then
everything else did some current statute
kicks in so that's all the amendment
does
any questions
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman I wondered if the
Prime sponsor of the amendment would be
able to find out for me how an officer
gets to know when 300 days is up when
they are stopping someone on the side of
the road
oh defer maybe I see people from the
Department of Safety here maybe they can
answer that question because the same
question applies to how does an officer
know when somebody's 60 days is up
um anybody from the direction Department
of Motor Vehicles want to chime in on
I don't mean to throw you on the spot
but
John marasco director of division of
motor vehicles
um just speaking with Captain Vetter in
the back this is this is one of those
areas where it is a gray area
um there's no way to truly tell that
um information unless you have
information that comes to you for
example if somebody were to move here
from another state and they've got the
out-of-state license plate on their
vehicle and it stays on the vehicle for
a prolonged period of time you may have
somebody that calls the police or
highlights that to the town clerk to let
them know that this played Sierra but
the person's been living here for
greater than 60 days it would have to be
some type of mechanism that comes in at
roadside you're not going to be able to
ascertain that because you're not going
to be able to ask for uh you know a
never Source bill or anything of that
nature with a date on it so that's why
to your point Mr chair the uh that
60-day window that 50 59 days if you
will driving on the Home Country license
which is the gray area and your
rationale for what what the committee is
taking uh before it today
um
it's not something that's easily
enforced so
it makes sense
thank you for that do you think with the
h2a VISA holders it would be easier to
ascertain especially with investigation
because they actually have documents and
dates saying when they applied for the
Visa I don't know if it says when they
actually got on a plane but do you think
it could be easier for them versus just
somebody moving here from out of state
I think the paperwork is a great place
to start yes my understanding is on that
Visa it's good for three years so you
could you could certainly look at
um when that went into effect and then
try to calculate it from there as to how
long they've been in the state
not to again not to put you on the spot
but you mentioned three years when I
looked it up I saw one year with two
extensions is that the same or is that
actually
treating it annual on an annual basis
yeah that that's a good question I I
don't know I was told that it was uh
from supervisors at the DMV it was a
three-year maximum three-year
Visa but I'd have to look into okay well
I looked at it yesterday it is
year by year one year with two
extensions so thank you very much so
that that would give you a better
timetable then right looking at that
document did that answer your question
representative Hill
I think it does I think I heard that
um
that we wouldn't know when at the
roadside we wouldn't know when it was
299 days or
360 days is that accurate
I think it's going to be depending
um
depending on when when the person came
in you could look at the paperwork but
um you know if they if they went back to
in this case Jamaica and then came back
again
um you're not going to necessarily know
that no but it's I guess it's very
similar to what we're doing now with the
59-day window until the 60th day
um it's very difficult to ascertain
exactly how long somebody's been in the
state and if they've reached that 60-day
Mark and again cap I know uh with uh
with highway safety is there anything
I'm missing here okay
so it is it is a gray area it's
basically a conversation at roadside
that would help you develop how long the
person's been in the state you're hoping
that they're going to be somewhat honest
with you on that and if they're not then
it's probably going to have to come in
through a third party or observation of
something else like a plate or paperwork
that you can use to triangulate how long
good
would you want to follow up
I
I do but I I will Reserve thanks thank
you very much director thank you anybody
see none I'll call the question on the
amendment
so we won't bother with the roll call I
don't believe I'll start with a Voice
vote so the motion is
um to adopt amendment number two zero
two three dash one eight two three h all
those in favor say aye
aye opposed nay
okay so the amendment is adopted Now we
move on to ought to pass as amended
on Senate Bill 187 any further
discussion from the committee
seeing none the amendment pretty much
does it
um with no other discussion I'll ask the
clerk to call the roll motion is
ought to pass as amended on Senate bill
187.
Vice chairman Gorski yes
yes clerk votes yes representative Hill
yes representative Dumas yes
representative Melvin yes representative
foot yes representative C yes
representative sellers yes
representative Sykes
yes representative Rich yes
representative power again yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative yes
representative Schultz yes
representative Jones yes representative
Jack yes representative stock yes
chairman Walsh
yes 20-0
okay so our recommendation is adopted
20-0
consent's been moved any objections
consent that is I'll close the executive
since this has a financial note can it
be on consent what's that since it has a
at this at this rate at this level yes
okay thank you and and if it's not for
whatever reason we'll be notified
but our the committee wishes are consent
so
all right I'll close the executive
session on Senate bill 187.
uh next up 188 there is also an
amendment on this if you don't have a
copy there are some right over here give
okay I'm gonna open up the executive
session on Senate Bill 188 relative to
catalytic converters
chair recognizes representative sellers
for a motion
thank you Mr chair uh motion to for SBA
188 FN
ottp motion is ought to pass is there a
second
uh Vice representative Fox
Bill's open to further Amendment
uh oh wait a minute sorry I apologize I
can't recognizes representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman
I would like to move uh Amendment
2023-1839h
emotions to adopt um Amendment 1839 H is
second by representative Gorski did you
care to speak to emotion uh it's fairly
self-explanatory
um to the existing RSA 263 colon 12
Roman 10 it simply adds three words
um scrap metal dealer to the Litany of
people that would be um
covered under this section
that's it
thank you sir uh what it also
um it does remove
Roman 13 which is mandating company
checks only
um just I just felt when I put this
together it was a I don't know not wise
to eliminate the use of legal tender
um and lastly it does change the
correction in drafting
um referring to 26212 it should be
referring to 263 12. so that correction
is there as well anybody else on the
amendment representative Sykes
yeah just like to voice my support for
the amendment these are common sense uh
tweaks if you will to the bill making it
a better bill
thank you sir anybody else
okay question is on Amendment 1839 H all
those in favor say aye
opposed name
okay
um the amendment is adopted brings us
back to a motion of ought to pass as
amended
on Senate Bill 188 anything else anybody
else from the committee
seeing none again motion is ought to
pass I'll ask the clerk as amended I'll
Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
James yes representative Melvin yes
representative foot yes representative C
yes representative sellers yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Rich yes representative Horrigan yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative yes
representative Schultz yes
representative Jones yes representative
Jack yes representative yes and chairman
Walsh
yes 20-0
our recommendation is adopted 20-0 and
Senate Bill 188
and is there a motion for consent
representative Sykes
moves consent without any any objections
seeing none consent that is I'll close
the executive session
uh next up is Senate Bill 256. give us a
there is an amendment on this also if
yeah
foreign
thank you
alrighty I'm going to open up the
executive session on Senate Bill 256 FN
establishing a safety program for off
I don't have one
I'm looking now I'll ask anybody in the
okay representative Sykes yeah I move a
lot to pass
representative Sykes moves ought to pass
is there a second I'll second at you
representative Sykes would you care to
don't we do them
oh yes sir you're right I don't have any
membership so it's going to be hopefully
someone else yeah this is uh the motion
is ought to pass it is open for further
Amendment
um I I can move the amendment to yeah I
got it now you gotta know okay
representative sakes yep yeah
um
I met I would uh also move uh Amendment
2023-1570
um to this
ought to pass motion the amendment
essentially just second first
representative sorry
um motion is to adopt Amendment uh 15
and 70 is there a second
by representative Rumbo sorry about that
representative Mike I'm sort of doing
this on the Fly
um kind of fun isn't it yeah it is
signified
um basically this is just a change in
the date uh to uh
F to make it affect its Effectiveness
States and uh basically it's a
housekeeping measure rather than
anything substantive to the bill and in
in support of the actual bill itself two
I would just make a note that as I
previously noted from
um AAA uh testimony about things it's
enforcement and quote education that
makes a difference and this adds an
important step to ohrv operators
education
thank you sir anybody else on the
amendment
uh one other minor detail the amendment
does is just clarify on or after those
dates which was missing from the first
draft with nothing else on the amendment
um
um yeah to adopt the motion is to adopt
the amendment uh two zero two three one
five zero H uh all those in favor say
aye aye op what was his name
okay
so the amendment is adopted we'll move
back to the motion of ought to pass as
amended anything else from the committee
anybody else wish to speak
representative Gorski thank you Mr
chairman um
when I read this bill and when I heard
testimony the way I look at this bill
it's almost like legislation to be
anti-fun
and to me to require all this
certification is just not something that
I'm too keen on so I'm going to be
thank you sir anybody else in the
committee
representative bayu
I see this bill as kind of helping to
alleviate some of the conflict with
landowners that
helps preserve some of the trails that
we have from being closed off because
people aren't respecting the property so
this
kind of to me is kind of the opposite of
of
uh
it's it's helping to preserve fun in
that way so
thank you
anybody else representative sellers
thank you Mr
my concern with the bill is is I think
we discussed was
it uh it has start dates and you know if
you're 46 years or 45 years old you have
to have a a course or if you're 36 and
26 and I I would think that the stock
date would be a lot better if it was
like this would be started as of today
or or January 1st 2024 so for everyone
at that point so no one that if you're
25 you don't have to have a license or
27 you do and you know so at this point
here it's saying you know hey I've
already been used in recreation vehicles
for X number of years and now I have to
go and get a take a course and have a
license so
I think there's just a lot of confusing
in this bill and I think a start date
should be instead of these different
dates of starting and how old you are so
I think that's a problem with it and I'm
not going to be supporting the ought to
pass
thank you sir anybody else from the
committee
representative Smith
I might agree with all that if you
couldn't drive them on the roads which
you can there are towns that have opened
up their roads to them and state
highways up north
to we did this a few years ago and found
that some of these ohrvs are larger
faster and more powerful than some
streetcars
they're running on the roads on tires
that say not for on-road use or not for
Highway use
letting somebody know all of that and
not assuming that it's safe to go I
don't know that that just makes sense to
me if they were just operating on the
trails I'd probably feel differently
about it but that's not those current
yeah and I'll just add I have gone back
and forth on this one there are good
points on both sides
so in an unusual move
I have no idea what I'm going to do but
I'm going to figure it out real soon
with nothing else
um
you've been asked the clerk to call the
roll and she's ready the motion is ought
foreign
Gorski no
representative Smith yes
clerk votes yes representative Hill
yes representative Dumas yes
representative Melvin no
representative foot
no
representative C yes
representative sellers
no representative Sykes
yes representative Rich yes
representative Oregon yes representative
Fox yes representative Rambo yes
representative yes representative
Schultz yes representative Jones yes
representative Jack yes representative
for one issue because I remember when I
was told after using a boat for 25 years
goodness fifteen to five
motion about to pass as amended is
adopted 15 to 5. this will go on regular
calendar I'll close the executive
session on Senate bill 256.
okay
last day let me get organized for a
minute but I'd like to get our
the people who are going to defend these
on the floor I get that list already and
the other thing I want to go over is
where the committee feels on the on the
bills that the Senate has amended so we
can get those taken care of concurred
and unconcurred I would suspect Thursday
and finally I do have lists if you
forget but at the last time we were here
I'm hoping to start putting together our
subcommittees on the retained bills I
did get an email from you representative
sellers on which ones you were
volunteering for but we'll talk about
that in a minute so give me a couple
minutes don't all run off yet we'll get
did you want the committee report on
Senate Bill 188 the converters I know
no
no 188 converters you did that one right
did you want to do the report on that or
no
um
any volunteers for the auto passes
is that defending on the floor if needed
as well sure okay
thank you very much sir uh we do have
representative Gorski doing a Minority
Report on 256. is the other split one we
had 118.
do we have a Minority Report on 118.
it was eleven nine yeah
all right
um last thing really on our agenda the
Senate did amend
uh make sure I've got this here
one
eleven
well they amended three of them actually
I'll give it to you in just a second
I've got the only copies I have from the
clerk
are 111
um
well nothing's on the calendar yet oh I
mean it's in terms of extended
amendments
well it has because they gave the Senate
so I can go over these in a minute I
just want to confirm that we only have
three
Carol do you have a couple of these
we know we can do representative Sykes
yeah
my records are three and if we're
missing one we will have another
opportunity to get caught up if the
clerk finds it I mean
okay
well I've got Brad checking too so let's
yeah
all right I just want to get the uh
opinion of the committee on these
amended Senate amendments on 111 which
was establishing the committee to study
electrical vehicle charging
for residential renters
changes it from three Senators to one
something that is done all the time
oh yes they did add
um
they're going to go to at least one
meeting damn it
oh
no that's a different Bill you're
thinking about with the camp counselors
no is it yeah 111 the only thing they
did was change it from uh three Senators
to one as you all know I did not vote
for this bill in committee I missed the
floor vote but in all fairness I'm only
going to talk to the Senate Amendment
which makes the change I have no problem
with the concur what's the opinion of
the committee
concur
okay concur it is uh Senate bill I mean
House Bill 137 an act relative to the
boating safety equipment rules and
vessel numbering rules this one is where
and I added
the New Hampshire Camp Directors
Association
I don't know that's going to be my
speech on the floor I don't see any harm
it just adds another person to this
um this this commission I where this
committee I don't remember hearing from
him in our our public hearing but it
really doesn't matter concur
okay
and the last one
yeah a special number plates for Liquor
Commission they actually added the
Senate Clerk
so
Clerk of the Senate Clerk of the Senate
uh you know it's it's interesting I
watched the public hearing I thought
they were going to be making a change
about the color of the executive Council
plates but it's not here so the only
thing is the addition of the Senate
okay
um the only other thing I've got is
please after this come on up and let me
know if you want to get on any of our
retained bills
huh relative to driver education House
Bill 55
tint window tint bills which I think we
can do with one study committee
and I know eliminated vehicle inspection
mandate for non-commercial vehicles I
will be getting on that
and then there's also 650. so instead of
taking up a lot of time now because I
know we want to move on please reach out
to me I am going to form study
committees on these because these are
real retains I want to get Felix some
answers on a few of these so yeah
fair enough
let's do it after
so I would if there are no other
questions I just want to thank everybody
we got through it again one more day on
the floor and that'll be it for this
year so again thanks and I'll see you